you guys support if there was a lot like
next year they're like this is
ridiculous and they said we're banning
no trans women can compete in the
women's division would you support that
um
yeah because you know we're women we
want to compete with yeah
and i want to work hard um and compete
against women and yeah i'm paying
against women and know that i'm not like
at a deficit and i'm trying i'm not
competing i'm doing all this but because
i am not as good as this person is not
because this person is physiologically
environment biologically like stronger
and in physicality
like i'd rather it be a fair playing
field
my skill level is not up to your skill
level yeah yeah so
why do you guys hesitate because it's
like a part of it is unfair because it's
like
we're we're in a society now where
people are allowed to be at to identify
us whoever they want to be so it's kind
of hard to say like yeah you're allowed
to be a woman but you're not allowed to
take part in women's school
what if i said i identify as a teenager
and started blowing high school kids out
of the water
that
is subject
yeah so shouldn't it just be like what
it is
like you can identify what you want in
your personal life but don't you think
from like a policy perspective it should
just be like what it is
because my thing is like if we can't
even advocate for ourselves how do we
expect men to advocate for us if we
can't even advocate for ourselves
it's it's hard because you also want to
be inclusive be inclusive and be
respectful respectful of those decisions
yeah of their choice but
i would tell that to a trans person i
literally i would say and i would say it
in a nice way like look i don't want to
get my ass beat by y'all yeah cuz
yeah i don't want to i'd rather league
or like the playoff finals yeah
i'm versus like a trans woman yeah like
that i would be pissed off yeah because
essentially like skill level could be
neck at night but you're always going to
have a leg up on somebody because you
used to be a man i like women didn't
have that opportunity to
go
be a man for a second to get all the
physicality of a man and then be able to
go back to women's force and i'm not
saying that that's what they're doing
but it's like that's what that's what as
women like you're missing the only way
we can get that is if we start taking
testosterone and we start taking things
that
give us that leg up
so yeah